era muito bom dia a todos
para quem não conhece chama pedro simon
hoje vou fazer aqui há uma comparação o
que o faz no treino e o que acontece na
nossa vida mas com todos mas só comigo
contou
como exemplo a ficar o que aconteceu nem
vida
mexe na realidade acontece com todos eu
deixo de deus muito jovem tenho sempre a
dupont esporte atualmente tem 44 anos
ainda ligado ao desporto e faz uma
modalidade chama criado a natação tem
ciclismo tem corrida que acontece hoje
26 anos o evento entre muitos outras
coisas que aconteceram na vida de seis
anos teve um acidente em que ia
acontecer a atenção pra minha perna
direita
nessa altura com 26 anos parece que já
já tinha elevado a vida tenha terminado
o meu percurso ida aos 28 anos descobri
até conseguir andar com uma perna
artificial para quem tem estado durante
alguns anos todos ligados aos cortes
nomeadamente né no atletismo
logo não tenho que ver se a correr
novamente tinha com novamente e desporto
aos 30 anos já perdi um pênalti social a
perna com as características essenciais
para conter e comecei no atletismo aos
32 anos já tinha quase nada alguns
recordes nacionais e cria entrar na alta
competição
mas aí já era velha
gera um problema com 32 anos é o velhote
já não tinha muito futuro mas começou
muito teimoso
fui sempre fui sempre
conhecemos dia pra frente
ora e de fui mais do atleta e já passei
a fazer triatlo não tem mais mais duas
novidades que acontece
entrei na alta competição por encontra
em risco
em 2008 foi vice campeão da europa de
triatlo em em 2011 foi vice-campeão do
mundo de triatlo na distância longa
distância longa sabe 3.800 144 km de
natação 180 quilômetros de bicicleta e
são uma maratona e correr 42 quilômetros
o indivíduo foi em vida com uma perna
artificial e já com rotulado com velho é
complicado
ora aqui está um mês atrás no campeonato
do mundo com 44 anos já sou muito mais
velho
aos 32 anos já não tem hipótese nenhuma
tudo isso porque procurei me avante
sou muito teimoso manter sempre a cabeça
tudo isto vou contar esta efe - os
pequenos episódios da minha vida porque
pra comparar o que eu faço que acontece
durante durante os meus treinos durante
os treinos
instruímos os quais mantemos a treinar
o objetivo do treino e destruir toda a
fibra muscular o mais possível pré foi
durante o descanso
uma boa alimentação uma boa argumentação
acontecer é super compensação para a
composição é com o coração após tran que
depois vem em maior capacidade de no
outro dia conseguir superar um treino
ainda muito mais duro ainda muito mais
chance
ora eu falei na alimentação na sua
alimentação suplementação que é não é
mais cálculo que ajuda a recuperar as
fibras musculares ficaram mais fortes
agora pergunto como é na vida como a
vida é como a vida nos ajuda é ficar
mais forte como é que não vida nos
ajudam a ficar mais forte
todos aqui os eventos que nós possamos
na vida muitas vezes foi o meu caso
quando perdi a perna
parece que o mundo desabou parece que já
não aceita passar na roleta da região
até que muitas vezes vamos como algo
mais fácil como ok olha a terceira
chance um quarto mas temos a cabeça e
não vamos à outra
eu que nunca fiz
em pelo menos por muito tempo
ninguém é herói na altura quando as
coisas acontecem muitas vezes gente
vamos atp mas o bebê tenha sido hoje
levantar a cabeça e renascer das cinzas
costuma dizer que vi e isso faz nós o
ser humano é uma máquina perfeita
muitas vezes a gente temos que sempre a
luta não não podemos baixar os braços
o coxa nos faz sofrer amanhã faz mais
fortes mais rápido hoje para poder
superar as crises nos momentos mais
difíceis
agora continuamos a falar através de
muita dessa movimentação
qual é a vossa segmentação
vocês vão responder é a segmentação de
vida pra mim pode portanto é algo é algo
que vai ajudar a comprar as fibras dos
claros alguma aumentar alimentação que
não posso fazer o almoço jantar tem
muitas vezes têm que tomar nossa
argumentação para conseguir comprar mais
rápido fazer conseguir fazer um treino
mais duro mesmo na vida da nossa vida no
dia-a-dia a nossa movimentação será
porque nós
os acidentes os erros que cometemos
quando vamos ao pt quando sentimos em
baixo
essa é a nossa recomendação de não se
alimentar disso conseguimos superar
supra a vida e sejam muitas vezes por
exemplo há muita gente que vai passar na
rua marcial vem com tô nem aí nota nada
são em vida normal
gostoso velho na rua 10 00 na rua uma
perna daquelas e
o que acontece desde 8 de 8 bi no
conselho é que não sei fazer isso e
muitas vezes
utilizemos isso acho que agora vou
carregar no botão certo tanto quando
vêem como perto destas muitas vezes se
confrontava inicialmente era intimidador
estou mais intimidado com você e do
próprio momento já que foi na rua que as
pessoas olharem para mim já nada disso
na oferta e normalmente as pessoas
coitadinho não sei que mais e serve
serve nem pra conseguir tão vai assoprar
algumas dificuldades têm sequer consegue
porque não consigo muita gente em um
confronto com isso foi fazer o desporto
eu faço porque viu a fazer isso com
sérgio também consigo que muitas vezes é
preciso olharmos esse exemplo nós já
sofremos aqui porque nos superar e
conseguir conseguir sempre aproveitar um
negativo para fazer algo positivo lá
essa eu n 51 a nossa suplementação no
dia a dia na nossa vida é viral além da
alimentação e da luta enfrentar
problemas nem pra mim nem que para isso
tenha que sofrer algum dano
isto porque não não é necessário andar
nos com medo de arriscar
temos que tentar não conter os erros do
passado mas jorge como ter sempre pensa
e faz parte da vida e vamos ter que a
gente quer sempre um pouco um pouco com
alguma urgência mas não sempre arriscar
e se errarmos vamos aprender
vamos aprender a superar a soprar a
melhora a vida e porque sei quando vou
voltar ou ficar mais forte é uma
realidade cada vez que vejo como vento
fica mais forte
nem tudo nem tudo na vida viu por nos
abater
muitas vezes já frente a gente quando
acontece alguma coisa é para agora
agora já não têm hipótese então não
pensa de maneira diferente que o que eu
faço quando acontece uma coisa que não
sou deputado quando uma prova cor mal
quando alguma vida um corre mal as
coisas correm bem graças a deus poucas
coisas coisas correm bem e isso é que se
deve pensar
graças a deus poucas coisas correm bem
porque o resto da vida fosse uma
maravilha não tinha gostei ou não não
sabíamos não sabíamos mas eu gosto das
coisas boas da vida
graças a deus acontece em tantas coisas
mais desagradáveis que é pra gente
quando acontece verdadeiramente uma
coisa que a gente pode colar barco que é
boa a gente jogar à mente é bom sujeito
na sempre milhões
a gente até se habituar com ele
mostrando como enrolar o engenheiro
senha é que está muito vai gastar muito
é maravilhoso mesmo mas também andaram
sempre primeiro orange doce que eu já vi
já só um é que quando vai o menos - gol
aqui já não sabe aí temos que saber
falar as coisas coisas mas daremos gosto
das coisas verdadeiramente hoje e tem
que ser que durou pouco tempo
o nome de um pouco tempo nem todo viu a
vida veio para nos abater mas sim para
nos tornar mais fortes
se cometemos algum erro vamos aprender
eu já venci o brasil e minha vida tem
sido baseada nisso tem sido sempre
aproveitar a vida do melhor possível e
tentar arriscar sem mais tentar ir
sempre procurar novos desafios tentar
sempre irá falar uma coisa mais gostosa
acontece a 50 mas nem sempre sou atleta
o atleta
é só o ser humano mas sempre que o vento
sempre que o vovô até o psm convento
tenho a sensação que sou mais forte
nunca é tarde pela luta nunca esqueça
nunca tarp ea outra quando a gente
conhecer os termos lá embaixo no outro
dia podemos estar lá no andar de cima é
precisa e não baixaremos os braços e
tudo isso por que tentar transmitir que
a vida havia uma academia da vida
o nosso percurso de ida leva nos
a primeira vez mais quanto maior quanto
maior for a experiências não estiver em
dúvida maior é essa teoria maior é é e
popular e com mister durante durante a
vida
atualmente
tudo isto mostrar aqui esta fotografia
não transmitem fotografias porque senão
esta fotografia aqui com 44 anos há um
mês e meio atrás no campeonato do mundo
em que toda a gente dizia com 30 anos 32
anos chegaram a dizer que não tinha
capacidade para suportar uma prótese
provavam deitava motta pt
essas pessoas já estavam atp hoje com 44
anos
sou mais forte mais rápido
e não vou parar por aqui ok era a
mensagem que trazia nos transmitir
acho que eu me concentro no tempo sempre
bater o record e acho que eu recordo é
ainda faltam dois minutos
muito obrigado